we've driven to this remote region with
the team from the frankfurt serological
society we have to continue on foot up
to an elevation of 2600 metres we want
to find out more about one of the shyest
animals of Manu National Park Lausanne
Dino is typically the Andean bear is
typical is this mountain range there are
many different ecosystems here the
catchment areas of rivers are an
important habitat we call the Indian
bear the Gardner of the forest it eats a
lot of fruit and because it migrates so
far it disperses the seeds which
promotes the spread of plants in the
area what's special about these mountain
forests is that they sometimes have a
tropical sometimes an Alpine character
depending on how much light heat and
water they get Roxana Rockets is heading
a project here researching the life of
the spectacled or Andean bear she
installs camera traps along age-old
trails the Incas once used because the
Bears would also rather use the trails
than fight their way through the dense
vegetation only a few people have seen
andi'm bears in the wild but you can
find evidence of them
castanos marques melo spoke at the
palace he remarks from a bear that
climbed up into this tree you can see
exactly where he clawed into it this
one's even better it's four claws
latched on here so he could get off the
tree I mean let's say it says here his
droppings and you see the small seeds
they're everywhere it's quite a large
pile unfortunately the rain hasn't
washed it away it's all still here
there are said to be just under 25,000
Andean bears left in all of South
America their habitat the dense mountain
forest is steadily diminishing the Bears
are now so rare that it's hard to find
out anything about their habits you need
plenty of intuition and a bit of luck
these marks are from Sacre a young
animal like all Andean bear Sacre likes
to climb to build a nest or just to get
an overview on this day sacré returned
once it was dark
in the evening Roxanna and her team
evaluate the pictures from the camera
traps an old acquaintance turns up her
tune who keeps away from humans but
loves to loot their corn fields then
Roxanna and her colleagues have to get
going again up to 2800 meters to
register the incident and gather
evidence now let's take a look at this
here are a few marks that show how the
bear eats the maize he does just the way
we do first he uses his paws and then he
removes the Cubs with his claws
sometimes he leaves Cubs in and you can
see the claw marks very well here for
example quite forcefully and as you see
the bear is in absolutely everything
attuned simply couldn't resist the smell
of the corn he ate his fill that the
farmers expense how can her tune be
prevented from further raids on the
field the next time he visits her tunes
should find the smell of the field quite
repellent with the pungent acrid scent
of the Chili Peppers Roxanna is burning
here a tune who relies on his sense of
smell will find that pretty repulsive
but they know that her tune migrates far
and wide he'll find another cornfield
elsewhere together with local farmers
Roxanna and her team have to find ways
to avoid conflicts with wild animals
it's not easy to campaign for the
protection of Andean bears when the
farmers themselves are struggling to
survive
I have to say the beer actually does
reduce our yields if it went because
it's really a lot of work making sure he
doesn't do any damage the frankfurt
zoological society's projects aim to
offer people an alternative to farming
in order to avoid future conflicts with
wild animals
weaving perfected over the centuries is
an art that interests designers and
boutiques the world over one project is
enabling women to sell their textiles at
a profit not only do they earn a higher
income with it
they can also depict the manure National
Park biosphere reserve in their textiles
especially the animals you find here
every textile they make reflects their
lives they present a picture of the
reserve with all its wildlife los
animales que aqui manu is one of the
world's most biodiverse
national parks the contact with wildlife
isn't always a source of artistic
inspiration is a contact oh I see km
poco affix contact often leads to
friction let's say a farm animal
disappears or dies people immediately
blame the Bears of the Pumas of course
the wild animals eat a lot of corn it's
one of the main problems we have in this
area
coexisting with wild animals often
creates a certain amount of resentment
in humans but that resentment can't be
allowed to lead to the extinction of a
valuable species
you